it has been a wild 24 hours of news we
will talk about the Tucker Carlson
firing the Don Lemon firing we will look
at new interviews from Ron DeSantis and
Donald Trump showing what a very ugly
2024 Republican primary might look like
but the big news Joe Biden announcing
that he is indeed running for
re-election in 2024
if he were to win he would best his own
record of the oldest age to start a
presidential term remember that Joe
Biden already the oldest president ever
to start a presidential term at 78 when
he was inaugurated in January of 2021
second would of course be Ronald Reagan
at age 73 Joe Biden would be 82 I
believe if my math is right and my
recollection and my facts at the start
of a second term but can he get there
well that is of course a different
question the New York Times headline
today Biden announces re-election bid
defying Trump and history while the
president once pitched himself as a
bridge to a new generation of democratic
leaders he has decided that he is not
ready to turn the torch over yet there
may be
an event sometime later this week of
with another announcement uh but for now
this is the announcement and there is
all sorts of speculation that honestly I
will mention but I don't think is that
useful to just really dwell on
everything from
Biden doesn't really plan to stay all
the way to the election this is a
placeholder because it would hurt him to
say now that he's not running for
reelection but he has to say something
because Trump's running and DeSantis
might soon be getting in and he can't
just do nothing but he's going to be a
placeholder for the eventual nominee
when Biden bows out well we have no
evidence that that's the plan of course
you can always assert that someone is
lying and they have some real plan
behind the scenes but we don't have
evidence of that right now much of this
is driven I think by two things Joe
Biden's age and again the fact that he
once did Pitch himself as a bridge as a
transitional president who might only
serve for one term if any of those
scenarios happen we are going to have
time to discuss and to analyze but it
doesn't seem very worthwhile to invest
time in that right now now what I think
is more interesting to look at is where
are the polls today and do Democrats
want Biden to run let's start with
polling there is a a plethora of polling
hypothetical polling which says if it's
Biden versus DeSantis or if it's Biden
versus Trump what are people saying
right now a new poll released today from
ipsos Reuters has Biden ahead of
DeSantis by nine
and Biden ahead of Trump by five this
poll is out of step with other polling
in two ways number one in most polling
Biden does better against Trump than
DeSantis in this poll Biden does better
against DeSantis it's also different
um in that the numbers are are you know
if you look at most of these other polls
we're talking about tied all the way up
to like plus four plus five and plus
nine is not something that we are seeing
we similarly have another poll released
two days ago for morning consult which
has Biden plus four over DeSantis and
plus one over Trump
and then a number of other polls in
which Biden does better against Trump
than DeSantis but the early numbers and
they are worth a little bit but not that
much right now are that Joe Biden for
the most part is polling ahead of the
two most likely Republican uh
challengers in 2024. this gets us to the
third component of this discussion which
is are voters happy with the most likely
choices which are Biden and Trump and
the answer is no not really and we
talked about this yesterday on the bonus
show a little bit oh the bonus show
where you want to make money sure
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad yeah we made money
yesterday on the bonus show talking
about this majorities don't want Biden
and Trump to run in 2024. a new NBC News
poll found that 60 of Americans think
Trump should not try to retake the Oval
Office including roughly a third of
Republicans at the same time 70 percent
of them Americans think Biden shouldn't
seek a second term including 51 percent
of Democrats a majority of Democrats
don't believe Biden would seek a second
term now what we spoke about yesterday
with producer pat on the bonus show is
just because you would rather a
different Choice doesn't mean if you're
a Democrat you're going to vote for
Trump or if you're a republican you're
going to vote for Biden it doesn't mean
that and I do think that all of the data
points us to if these are the choices
even if you'd rather someone else if
you're not a trump person you're not
going to vote for Trump just because
you'd rather someone other than Biden
and vice versa now I want to go one step
further you all know
I've not been a Biden cheerleader I
don't find Biden electrifying or
exciting or any of it but I try to
evaluate presidencies
as objectively as possible
and I'm going to have a deeper dive on
this for you soon
when I look on paper as the kids say
it's hard to argue that the Biden
presidency
is anything but one of the most
successful presidential terms in a very
long time I know I know Biden is not as
left as I would like and Biden was not
the guy I supported in the primary and
all these different things but when you
actually look at accomplishments
particularly in the context in which Joe
Biden is serving this first of
potentially two terms
it is really difficult to say that this
is not a very successful presidential
term it's crazy to think about I will
lay it out for you as a non-biden
cheerleader just looking to be as
objective as possible maybe we'll do
that tomorrow or Thursday maybe we'll
give it a little more time and look at
that next week but Joe Biden running for
reelection we are going to be watching
this election very closely we really are
you know we have this coupon code 24
starts now on our website
we really are in the midst of the 2024
election as quickly it feels like we're
still uh seeing Trump at 2 A.M the day
after the 2020 election
saying I guess I won
uh feels like it was just yesterday but
we really are ramping up here in the
2024 election and we're going to be
covering all of it for you Fox News
propagandist Tucker Carlson has been
fired by Fox News what was initially
reported as they have parted ways is
very clearly a firing as far as we know
as of uh Tucker's last show on Friday he
expected to be back on the air last
night we have
four different potential reasons that
may have played a role in what took
place and I will tell you about all of
them but do not be confused this is a
firing we have a report from The
Washington Post Tucker Carlson is out at
Fox News after dominion lawsuit
disclosures this is potentially one
element of the firing which is that the
discovery
from the Dominion lawsuit against Fox
News which led to a settlement of 787.5
million dollars in favor of dominion
included the release of text messages
from Tucker Carlson some of which
contain Tucker saying he hates Trump
passionately which is interesting but
also text messages in which Tucker
Carlson was criticizing Fox management
that's not a great thing if you were Fox
News and now you've got to deal with
this guy we also have this lawsuit that
is forthcoming related to harassment
taking place within the walls of the
Tucker Carlson production uh apparatus I
guess we would call it a woman has filed
a lawsuit and makes all sorts of very
very tough allegations and that is a
mess for Fox News as well in addition to
this we have potentially a forthcoming
lawsuit from Ray Epps Ray Epps is this
guy who was in Washington DC on January
5th 2021
and many people including Tucker Carlson
have made ray Epps's life a living hell
signal boosting conspiracy theories that
Ray Epps is some kind of uh agent
provocateur or FBI informant or whatever
the case may be who was trying to entrap
rioters by encouraging to them to go and
Riot when they had no plan to do so
there's no evidence of any of that and
there was a 60 Minutes piece on Sunday
just two days ago in which Ray Epps
specifically points to Tucker Carlson
and saying essentially he's made my life
a living hell that is also a lawsuit
concern so when you step back and you
think about it Tucker Carlson
responsible to some degree for giving
voice to those conspiracies that led to
the 787 million dollar settlement for
Dominion in addition to that that very
lawsuit releasing text messages from
Tucker Carlson that make it a little
awkward to have him work talking for you
you've got one lawsuit already with
another lawsuit potentially forthcoming
as good as his ratings were this guy is
really a headache for you and we have
video this was the end of Tucker what
ended up being Tucker Carlson's final
episode on Friday he says I'll be back
Monday and there is every indication
that he believed he would be back on the
air yesterday
truly that was a great segment and I'm
just grateful that you came on and I'm
especially grateful for the pie thank
you for having me appreciate it employee
of the week we're gonna we're just make
it of the Year Tyler morale of Coco's
Pizza that's it for us for the week
we'll be back by the way the entire
episode of let them eat bugs not quite
as good as Pizza streaming now on Fox
Nation is a promo code Originals for 30
days free and we'll be back on Monday in
the meantime have the best weekend with
the ones that you love there it is we'll
be back on Monday so every indication
that he would be back so listen let's
think through the larger implications
here will Tucker ultimately be replaced
with someone worse it's possible uh last
night Brian Kilmeade from Fox and
Friends filled in for Tucker and we'll
have a few seconds of that it was pretty
awkward a little bit later in the show
imagine the bigger picture though Tucker
Carlson was reportedly fired by Fox at
least in part for the things he said
about Fox management as revealed in the
Dominion lawsuit so in some incredible
way Trump's hair brained elect action
lies which led to the attacks on
Dominion which led to the lawsuit led to
Tucker's firing in a sense Tucker's
firing came
from the big lie about the 2020 election
in terms of whether it's good for the
country to have Tucker off the air what
will likely be temporarily because
Tucker is going to find something else
of course Tucker broke the brains of
millions of people
he was seen by many on the right as a
real thinker which is hilarious and so
in some sense the country is better off
with Tucker not spouting propaganda on
the other hand he'll find some other
place to do it it just won't be Fox
additionally Don Lemon was fired from
CNN yesterday that relates to what
happened with Tucker in some ways we'll
delve into that in more detail on the
bonus show later today so let's take a
quick break make sure you're subscribed
on the YouTube channel if you're just
listening today you can watch I know
it's crazy to think there's a video
component to this insane show that we do
every day but there is you can watch at
youtube.com the davidpackman show we're
going to take a quick break let emotions
simmer on set and then we'll be back
with much more in a moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
all right let's review some of the um
coverage I guess we would call it
including on Fox News of the firing of
Tucker Carlson some of this stuff is
really funny some of it's kind of sad
some of it's you know a little bit of
both or somewhere in between I'm going
to start with a clip of Harris Faulkner
Harris Faulkner has increasingly been
one of the more notable uh kind of
partisan hacks on Fox News I think is
the term that I would use in a lot of
different ways she devoted 35 seconds to
telling us that Tucker Carlson is no
longer going to be at Fox News she
falsely said that Tucker and fox agreed
to go their separate ways what's funny
about that term is like in a sense
anytime someone's fired the parties have
agreed that they won't work there
anymore in the sense that the person
who's fired doesn't really have a choice
like they leave and they don't show back
up so in that sense they've agreed but
the suggestion that this was Mutual is
of course wrong the funniest part of
this clip though is the delivery it's
almost like it's a eulogy at a funeral
but kind of even even weirder she's
really struggling through this let's
take a look we have some new
part ways yeah and again it's not really
mutual insofar as when you're fired you
kind of have to accept it
was this past Friday wow
news tonight will Air live at 8 pm
Eastern it will be an interim show with
rotating Fox News personalities until a
new host is named
we want to thank Tucker Carlson for his
service she's acting like this is going
to be the naming of a new pope you know
I mean and but but you know I'm not
Catholic so it's not like I even really
glorify the naming of a new pope but
when you consider the Pomp and
Circumstance around it she's acting like
at some point so or or the you know the
next uh the next Dalai Lama is going to
be selected as a host and prior to that
as a long-term contributor
wow so really only 31 seconds and then
four seconds of Silence there the the
funniest part is when she said that it
was Mutual for sure there was really
nothing Mutual about it then we go to
Charlie Kirk Charlie Kirk one of the
most I mean I would say prominent and
Powerful right-wing voices when it comes
to indoctrinating college and recently
College age people I think is a fair
um
a praise of sorts of Charlie Kirk he is
talking about Tucker as if Tucker died
almost it's like he just got fired he'll
do his propaganda elsewhere but Charlie
Kirk also sounds like he's eulogizing
Tucker Carlson here
some tech issues here too
Tucker Carlson re-made the right that is
one thing I will agree at The View on he
was more powerful than anybody else
since the death of Rush Limbaugh in
reshaping the rights in moving
the Overton window in pushing forward
positive narratives in challenging
operation Mockingbird
and say this is somebody who knows
Tucker very well he did not care about
the backlash right and he is still alive
I know you might think wow so Tucker
died I guess Tucker is alive he's just
been fired and he will I am sure I am
certain I'm confident he will continue
doing all of those things that Charlie
talked about uh just on a different
network and then the third reaction to
this and this I love this is a message I
can really get behind the third reaction
has been stop watching Fox News we need
listen they fired bongino now they fired
Tucker and Jesse Waters is on paternity
leave which I guess when Pete boot Edge
took paternity leave it was bad but
Jesse Waters can take paternity leave
it's all very strange but the message
that they've been coming up with is it's
time to not watch Fox News anymore that
is a message I can get behind here's
propaganda Steve Bannon suggesting that
approach which I said hey the reason to
watch Fox you got Maria in the morning
you've got you've got Jesse right he's
getting there but Tucker's really the
reason to watch Fox uh with this I don't
know why anybody needs to watch anything
on the Murdoch Empire because Tucker was
the Mainstay of the uh the populist
voice over at uh Fox and it's just the
Blockbuster news uh Tucker's announced
he's leaving and not just that the last
show was from Tucker didn't really
announce that he's leaving like even
that that's also not true Tucker hasn't
and Tucker on Friday thought he would be
back yesterday Tucker was fired he's
announced that he's leaving pretty night
so tonight they're going to replace it
with I don't know Fox News tonight or
something but no Tucker Carlson at Fox
News it looks like no Tucker Carlson and
Fox Nation the streaming service we'll
get more details of that yeah he's been
fired okay so he's he announced that
he's leaving listen the not watching Fox
I mean that Steve Bannon is known for
political
maneuvering that includes the use of
so-called chaos agents in fact there's
now a report and I I'm not saying that
this is actually completely accurate
it's a report and I haven't looked at it
yet but there's a report that
Bannon has been encouraging Bobby
Kennedy Jr to run against Biden not
because Bannon likes Bobby Kennedy Jr
but as a quote Chaos Agent a really
great Chaos Agent Type move would be
for the right to come out with a
campaign against Fox News that would be
an absolute and total Delight so I'm I'm
behind that stop watching Fox News the
way Steve Bannon says that was the
reaction from some on-air people let's
now look at the reaction at Fox News to
Tucker as firing from staffers
pure joy
pure joy is the way that Rolling Stone
describes the emotional circumstances
among staffers at Fox News over the
firing of propagandist Tucker Carlson
this is just delightful to see
Fox News and Tucker Carlson have parted
ways he's been fired the rest of the
network seems thrilled writes this
Rolling Stone article quote pure joy one
fox reporter told Rolling Stone of their
reaction to the split no one is
Untouchable it's a great day for America
and for the real journalists who work
hard every day to deliver the news at
Fox okay I don't know how many of them
there are a producer added quote it was
a good move to part ways with Tucker he
knowingly spread lies throughout his
time at Fox but I fear management will
replace him with someone who is just
like him so there probably won't be any
real change as I suggested earlier in
the show a network correspondent said
quote good riddance for a while there it
seemed like he was running the network
this clearly is a message that he's not
in the interim it's a morale boost for
sure so a lot of people at Fox happy
with this this decision and I think it
important to again insert into this
discussion
there is no reason whatsoever to believe
that Tucker Carlson was fired because
his on-air message became incompatible
with the ideology of Fox News everything
we know is that these are all really
sort of like Personnel and legal issues
uh Tucker Carlson
fomented the story lines that got Fox
News sued by Dominion
and paying out almost 800 million
dollars and currently under lawsuit by
smartmatic potentially paying out even
more money Tucker was part of that
Tucker was attacking Fox Management in
text messages which we learned about
because of that lawsuit Tucker and
alleged harassment taking place in his
staff among his staff environment uh it
has now led to a lawsuit by a woman and
the targeting of Ray Epps may lead to
another lawsuit against Tucker Carlson
and his program so he became a legal
problem he became a headache he became a
problem employee essentially but it is
not because Fox News decided oh we
really shouldn't have that ideology
needless to say the fact that fox
staffers are so thrilled about this is
fascinating another article from the LA
Times writes Tucker Carlson producers
discrimination claims go beyond Dominion
scandal
this is uh and I just lost the article I
don't know where it went Abby grossberg
sued Fox Fox News Tucker and several
producers late yesterday alleging the
network is Rife with sexist misogynistic
and abusive Behavior there are people
already saying that none of these
allegations are true and there are
people saying obviously they are we have
a lawsuit it's going to be adjudicated
okay but the lawsuit is another problem
a grossberg's lawsuit alleges
discrimination based on gender religion
and disability she alleges that quote
constant bullying and gaslighting caused
her quote so much stress and anxiety
that her stomach ulcers flared up and
she was in excruciating pain so that is
going to be investigated that is going
to be looked at and then of course we
have the potentially forthcoming lawsuit
from Ray Epps not good for Fox News it
was not mutual Tucker was fired but if
anybody is happy here other than
millions of Americans who rightly assess
that Tucker was damaging the country it
is Fox News staffers themselves pure joy
the exact quote from Rolling Stone all
right so what was on the air last night
when you would have expected to see
Tucker Carlson had he not been fired by
Fox news earlier in the day well it was
Brian Kilmeade now I admit
I was a little confused I get Brian
Kilmeade and Greg Gutfeld mixed up I
know that officially Gutfeld is a
comedian
and kilmead is a news guy
but you know how it is on Fox it's very
hard to tell what's what so I was
expecting to see Gutfeld hosting last
night but it kill meat is the guy from
Fox and Friends he acknowledges that
Tucker is gone but they're still friends
and then it is never mentioned again
take a look at this this is the intro
from last night's show Fox News
[Music]
hi everybody and welcome to Fox News
tonight I am Brian Kilmeade as you
probably have heard Fox News and Tucker
Carlson have agreed to part ways I wish
Tucker the best I'm great friends with
Tucker and always will be but right now
it's time for Fox News tonight so let's
get started
let's get started that clip from
decoding Fox News who does a great job
on Twitter if you're still on Twitter uh
you could follow decoding Fox News so
you know it's sort of like a Tucker's
great great friend of mine let's never
speak of him again now I I am going to
admit to you this is not unique to Fox
News I've been involved at
affiliate stations where I didn't
directly work there They Carried the
show and as you know radio is a
completely toxic industry where there's
no loyalty in any day someone could just
come on come in off the street and
replace you quite frankly
um but I've sort of been tangentially
involved in situations where someone has
just moved off of the schedule or fired
sometimes it's like a national show
that's dropped and then you get a call
and it's just sort of like Hey listen uh
we are going in a different direction
we've gotten rid of your friend whoever
are you okay with us uh re-running your
show and now running it twice a day sure
whatever you know it's like the the
situation kilometers is in the totality
of everything Fox News staffers happy
about this and lawsuits coming in and
Tucker's text messages being part of
this and Tucker's uh coverage leading in
part to the lawsuit that led to the 800
million dollar settlement all of that
stuff is crazy
the micro of like listen my boss has
told me to be here and I kind of have to
host this thing now but it doesn't mean
I hate Tucker that actually is awkward
and it is not Brian kilmeade's fault
um so it's more just like the final note
on this but I don't blame kill Mead for
anything I guess his alternative is like
to turn this down but nobody's gonna
turn down an opportunity like this even
if you're friends with Tucker and I am
sure that if you ask Tucker Tucker would
say no I don't hold it against Brian
that a boss called him and said hey do
you want to host more stuff uh it's
totally typical in normal the
awkwardness and the let's never speak of
it again and move on to an interview
with vivekarama Swami which is what
ultimately there was it's a funny visual
but this is the way that it always
happens all right all of these clips
will be on our Instagram you can search
Instagram for David Pacman show they
will be on our YouTube channel
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
they will be on our Tick Tock and yes
even on Snapchat we are now on Snapchat
very interesting platform actually which
I'll have more to say about at some
point in the future we're going to take
a quick break we'll look at the DeSantis
and Trump interviews after the break and
so many other things
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's look at a couple of interviews
from the last 24 hours from the two men
who if they both run are are the likely
Front Runners in the 2024 Republican
primary we're going to start with Ron
DeSantis and then look at Donald Trump
Ron DeSantis is on what according to
many is a very ill-advised trip to Asia
right now flooding and gas lines in
Florida
um all sorts of problems that are uh
self-inflicted quite frankly by Ron
DeSantis and he was in Japan yesterday
and I believe now in Korea really a
profile and courage in in South Korea
that has you you might imagine and uh
during the Hannity hour last night on
Fox News which I guess coincides
conveniently with the time difference
with where Ron DeSantis is Ron DeSantis
was interviewed now there's a logistical
problem and then there's a substance
problem the logistical problem as you
will notice is that somehow they set
DeSantis up
facing the Sun and he's squinting the
entire interview he looks visibly
uncomfortable now DeSantis often looks
visibly uncomfortable even in a well-lit
cool room but here he looks extra
uncomfortable so I don't know you know
this was a scheduled interview why they
have him staring into the sun I don't
really know maybe it's because Trump
stared at the eclipse that time and they
wanted to do the same thing unclear but
DeSantis generally
is just not really understanding how to
properly answer basic questions in this
clip Hannity asks DeSantis what happened
to your relationship with Donald Trump
here's his answer the last time I
interviewed president Trump I was there
in 2018
and I always saw the two of you as
friends and I said to him you guys were
friends it's a very simple question I
asked him I said what happened and I
think it's only fair to ask you the same
question what do you think happened
you know I enjoyed supporting him when
he was President we worked really hard
for his re-election in Florida and I
always had a good relationship with them
and then once the midterm election
happened he started taking shots at me I
didn't really do anything to do it
except do a good job but that's fine I
mean Sean you know when you're making
things happen you take incoming from a
variety of targets so that's just the
nature of the business and I'm happy to
I'm happy to stand strong and do what's
right all right guys I don't think
DeSantis can do it this is such a weak
answer by the standards of what
Republican voters want think of it now I
sent this isn't wrong listen the dentist
is accurately pointing out
he used to like me then he stopped
liking me when it became clear that
DeSantis wasn't backing down from
challenging Trump in 2024. this is how
it all started remember that what
happened was DeSantis was asked would
you consider running in 2024 and would
you commit to only doing it if Trump
isn't running and DeSantis didn't rule
out now I might run even if Trump trump
runs I might challenge Trump this was
seen as disloyal by Trump and that's why
all this started so desantis's
assessment is 100 correct Trump just
started going after me and I'm not going
to get involved in it
this is so pathetic and weak looking
from the standards of these Republican
voters he's basically saying
oh he just went after me and I'm doing
nothing
now you and I might say
you need someone taking the high road in
fact it would be better to have someone
who's not even involved in this nonsense
someone like a Mitt Romney or a Liz
Cheney or whatever else the case may be
I'm with you on a personal level but
this is weak stuff this is not going to
if you think Trump's got 52 right now
DeSantis has 24 and in order to win
DeSantis has to figure out some way to
get up to and Beyond 50 percent
this isn't going to help them just yeah
he started it he sounds whiny he sounds
pathetic and the interview continued and
it really isn't great for DeSantis here
um asked again about uh the the attacks
and he says I'm just going to do what's
right that's fine I mean Sean you know
when you're making things happen you
take incoming from a variety of targets
so that's just the nature of the
business and I'm happy to I'm happy to
stand strong and do what's right all
right Governor have a great trip we
appreciate you joining us and okay and I
thought we actually had new stuff there
but it seems sort of like a retread of
of uh a lot of the same stuff so this is
not a guy who you see and you say wow
projecting strength
projecting confidence
projecting an inspiring and electric
alternative Vision to what Trump gives
us hey you know what I was a trump
person maybe I'll go for DeSantis
instead it's maybe good enough to kind
of clean up the hangers on and the dregs
of the uh uh uh opposition to Trump that
is already there but it's not going to
coalesce people around you and
restructure the dynamic of this Primary
in a way that's going to let you win it
it's just not going to do any of that so
now the question for DeSantis is does he
even announce does he try to wait till
does he forget about the presidency
altogether does he risk possibly
humiliation quite frankly I mean it is
it is totally he really doesn't seem to
have what it takes and if he enters this
race with trumpet 52 and DeSantis at 24
and doesn't have some way to strongly
gain support he could end up truly
humiliated and uh it would be an
entertaining watch from a political
strategy standpoint be sort of a strange
thing so that's the DeSantis interview
from yesterday let's now look at the
Trump interview within hours of the
firing of Tucker Carlson failed former
president Donald Trump was interviewed
on Newsmax this is an interview as
confused as I have ever seen Donald
Trump one of the first things he was
asked about was his opinion on the
firing of Tucker and what's of course
very funny about this is that we now
know Tucker hates Trump Tucker's text
messages revealed in the discovery
process of that Dominion lawsuit which
ultimately led to a nearly 800 million
dollar settlement there was this text
message where Tucker said I hate Trump
passionately and I can't wait until we
can stop talking about him so Trump of
course knows that but I think Trump
still realizes that at least in some
some sense he may need an ally in Tucker
Carlson for his primary and for his
eventual general election campaign if he
gets there so here is Trump reacting to
the departure AKA firing of Tucker from
Fox so Tucker Carlson was sitting here
two weeks ago interviewing you he's gone
what do you make of that well I'm
shocked I'm surprised he's a very good
person a very good man and very talented
as you know and he had very high ratings
so
we're just learning about it almost as
we speak now a couple people wrote to me
and there's more to this which we'll
look at saying you know David
if you read the expression on Trump's
face this little smirk
Trump is saying one thing
but projecting another one with the
smirk and that's Trump's reaction which
is Tucker got what was coming to him
because he said bad things about me in
those text messages it's an
interpretation I don't know you make of
it what you will you and I just said wow
that was something that's a big one uh I
don't know if it was voluntary or was it
was somebody fired but I think Tucker's
been terrific he's been especially over
the last year or so he's been terrific
to me there's a lot of turmoil over
there at Fox I mean 787 they just paid
why would they get rid of a guy who's
performing why would somebody do that to
their business because they're losing
money right now their stock has gone
down well I was surprised that they made
a settlement on that case I thought that
was the case that should easily be won
and they made a settlement look you'll
have to ask them I'm not I'm not
representing them at all by any by any
means but the Tucker uh situation again
you don't know if it's a firing maybe he
left because he wasn't being given his
free reign he wants free reign maybe but
now of course we know that Tucker was
indeed fired and we know that there were
many problems Tucker's coverage
partially responsible for the lawsuit
that led to the settlement Tucker saying
horrible things about Fox Management in
text messages released as part of that
lawsuit Tucker currently sued for having
a discriminatory misogynistic sexist
racist uh uh uh production
apparatus and potentially another
lawsuit coming from rayap so Fox News
realized at least to some degree that
Tucker became a problem for them
continuing on this very confusing
Newsmax interview we saw DeSantis asked
by Hannity about Trump now we see Trump
asked by Greg Kelly about DeSantis and
Trump takes a different approach than
DeSantis did want to get to Nixon in a
moment by the way Rhonda santis do you
think he could be a good president
someday in like eight years 16 years I
mean you endorsed him once he's got some
Talent you're kind of crushing him right
now someday could he be president well I
endorsed him once and he was losing
badly and because of the endorsement he
wanted a landslide the following
literally the following day look right
now I'm very down on him I'm a Believer
in loyalty and I'm a Believer in other
things and he has obviously not run a
very good campaign because he's getting
he's getting crushed so now understand
that there is no campaign yet that's the
most interesting thing about this Trump
is acting as though DeSantis is running
a campaign now you could argue well he
sort of is but he hasn't announced
because he's feeling it out okay it's
not actually a campaign and there's a
question as to if and how the Dynamics
will change I really don't know how
don't know him you know I don't know him
that well I agreed to endorse him he
came over to see me he was one of a
hundred people that fought a little bit
on the impeachment hoax number one
impeachment hoax number two they were
hoaxes they were just hoaxes and based
on that I did it because I didn't know
the people he was running he was running
against a man that was way up in the
polls leading by a massive amount that
election was over when I endorsed him
the election was over in Ron's favor I
mean it was Ron was getting ready to
quit so I don't know I I'm very
disappointed in him because I'm uh a
loyal person maybe that's really what
this is all about he could have just
skipped to that to a fault I'm a loyal
person and somebody gets you into office
and then you're telling people well I
don't know if I'll run against the
president you know I mean life shouldn't
have to work that way and there it is
the anecdote I regularly refer to which
is DeSantis was asked would you rule out
running against Trump and he didn't rule
it out Trump remembers
Trump bringing up that anecdote he has
not forgotten about that the topic of
the January 6 riots came up as it often
does and uh listen to what Trump had to
say this this is really wild stuff the
weaponizing law enforcement at a level
that nobody's ever seen before and it's
very dangerous to the country and our
country is not going to stand for it you
know we have very strong people in this
country and they've been sitting back
and watching they've been watching
they've watched that the whole situation
at the Capitol they didn't walk in with
guns they shot Ashley Babbitt that
officer bad things should happen to him
he shot her
and she was totally defenseless she was
like an American Patriot you look at her
she was a patriot listen
that's been investigated and it's
interesting to continue to hear
the people who say we support the police
we defend the police
etc etc all of a sudden say hey even
though there was an extensive
investigation into the death of Ashley
Babbitt and the officer was found not at
fault
they insist that the officer did
something wrong why is that it's because
that principle of we support the police
only when it's convenient online the
flag and the whole thing
she was an American Patriot they shot
her and nothing happened to him if that
were the other way around it would have
been hell to pay but the people of this
country just aren't going to take it
anymore well I don't know exactly what
Trump means by that is he alluding to
violence is he alluding to how people
will vote we never know last clip Donald
Trump asked about his former Attorney
General William Barr
gets a little dicey and most of my
people were smart and tough I had some
bad ones I mean I wish I had a better
attorney general somebody that was
tougher that wasn't afraid to fight he
should have been fighting instead of
being afraid to be impeached he was
petrified of being impeached just
petrified it made him uh there's a
couple of words I could use I would
never use the word impotent of course
but
it made him
absolutely useless when it came to
election fraud and so many other things
and now he sits back and he pontificates
with you know some some of these uh
various shows that are on uh I wish I
had a better attorney general well
remember Trump ran on I will hire the
absolute best people and so by his own
standards if there is anybody to blame
for William Barr it is Trump himself so
this is what I expect to continue in
terms of DeSantis versus Trump whether
or not listen even if DeSantis doesn't
announce until the point at which
DeSantis says I'm not running if that is
what is coming this is what we're going
to see we are going to see Trump
continuing to attack the Santos for
disloyalty and DeSantis playing the I'm
too good for this I'm too classy for
this I'm above it thing which only makes
him look weak to the average Republican
voter we will have more we're going to
take a quick break Lindsey Graham had
his bubble popped on CNN yesterday and
many other things to discuss with you
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
Republican senator Lindsey Graham has
become very comfortable in the
right-wing propaganda bubble where
you're just allowed to kind of say
really whatever you want and it's not
really challenged in any way and he was
very triggered when he appeared on CNN
and Dana Bash quite honestly very gently
pushed back against like one little tiny
corner of what he was saying about
abortion and he didn't like it one bit
he didn't like being questioned in any
way and attacked her saying you're
covering for these people there's
actually some really interesting data
underlying what they're talking about
about abortion so let's listen to it
let's look at it then I'll talk to you
more I think the Republican party will
be in good standing to oppose late term
abortion like most of the Civilized
world
scars
no no your media you keep covering for
these guys they introduce legislation
that allowed abortion On Demand with
taxpayer-funded uh were you paying for
it the taxpayer up to the moment of
birth that was their position in
Washington That's the Law they want to
pass and nobody in your business will
talk about it is far better senator uh
I'm not covering for anybody and you
know that and when I have Democrats on
and I've had Democrats I've asked for
the fact I have asked many all of them
about their position on where uh where
they believe this issue should be okay
The Temper Tantrum by Lindsey Graham
accusing Dana Bash of covering for them
just because she inserted one little
measly fact into the discussion that is
a result of the propaganda bubble that
the Republican party is so used to
uh it's really important to understand
two parts of this first of all Dana Bash
is correct the Supreme Court decision in
1973 in Roe v Wade established that a
woman has a constitutional right to
terminate a pregnancy up to the point of
fetal viability which is generally
around 24 weeks of gestation
since Roe v Wade
with medical advances there have been
very limited uh instances
where a fetus was able to survive a week
or two earlier than that insanely rare
insanely risky but what we are talking
about here indeed with Roe v Wade which
is gone now okay but Dana Bash is
correct this isn't controversial Roe v
Wade dealt with the point of viability
generally considered 24 weeks but
there's another really important thing
to understand
abortions in general after 21 weeks
forget about 24 after 21 weeks are
really rare
difficult to get
costly time intensive and only even
performed by some providers now it
doesn't matter what you think is right
or wrong the point is something that
barely happens gets almost all of the
attention and the vast majority of
abortions get almost no attention
there's a very good graphic from the CDC
which we're going to put up on the
screen which shows that more than a
third of abortions are before six weeks
remember it usually takes five weeks to
even know you're pregnant
34 percent of abortions are before six
weeks a full 52 percent of abortions are
before seven weeks and then you you
stack up the numbers 99 of abortions are
before 19 weeks and when you look out at
this graph and you look all the way out
to 29 weeks
0.01 of abortions are happening at that
point and if you go beyond 19 Beyond 29
weeks it is statistically zero so
Lindsay is upset that Dana Bash
said oh Roe v Wade dealt with up until
the point of viability
what she should have said is Lindsay 91
of abortions happen before 13 weeks 99
of abortions happened before 19 weeks or
some formulation of that based on the
CDC data uh but they don't care they
don't want to talk about that and
instead they want to talk about
two days before the due date a week
after the due date and all of these
different things now let's divide that
up into two parts just so we're being
thorough
the after-birth abortions
I still am not totally sure where that
comes from it's it's not anywhere there
was a rumor from New York that they
started it was untrue there was a rumor
from Virginia they started it was untrue
so after birth abortion it's not even
worthy of our discussion the day before
the due date abortion
really
precise
statements about this were made in some
abortion hearings I want to say it was
about a year ago maybe a year and a half
ago and OB gyns and other medical
practitioners testified under oath about
this and they said listen just because
it might be legal somewhere to have an
abortion in the third trimester doesn't
mean that obese are just going to do it
and that it doesn't mean that people are
coming to us asking for that and
multiple OB GYN said it's never even
come up in my practice this scenario of
you're 37 weeks pregnant and you say hey
you know what
I think I just don't want a baby oh sure
we'll perform an abortion most OBS have
said it's not even come up the rare
cases where that happens you're talking
about the mother's life being at risk
and that it is just not a thing the way
that Republicans pretend that it is so
anyway Lindsay's all triggered because
one little fact was interjected I wish
Dana Bash had actually said more and
said why do you and your ilk insist on
focusing on a part of the curve that is
below
0.01 of all abortions which has been
widely discussed by OBS and we Now
understand the truth of it why do you
pretend like that's what abortion is but
she didn't do that
and fine she didn't think it was her
place to but Lindsay Lindsay's got to
settle down and get out of that
propaganda bubble a little more often
okay we recently told you about a pro de
Santa Super PAC which released its first
anti-trump bed we now have Donald Trump
posting a hardcore Ron DeSantis attack
ad to truth social
um and what's interesting is that some
of the claims that it makes it's a very
aggressive very vicious attack out but
the claims it makes aren't exactly
bulletproof which might not come as a
shock to you let's take a listen it was
struggling big time in his primary race
for governor of Florida polls revealed
DeSantis was failing so bad he was
losing by a staggering 17 points then
DeSantis was saved by the endorsement of
President Trump Trump's support was so
powerful just two days after the
endorsement DeSantis took commanding
lead and it propelled him to being
elected I'd like to thank our president
for standing by me when it wasn't
necessarily the smart thing to do you're
welcome Ron unfortunately instead of
being grateful DeSantis is now attacking
the very man who saved his career had
that time DeSantis remembers how he got
to where he is make America great again
big league so good build the wall then
Mr Trump said you're fired I love that
part truth is there's only one person
who can make America great again yeah so
you know this entire thing about how uh
the day at two days after the
endorsement DeSantis just shot up I
encourage you to go back and look at the
polls Real Clear Politics has like a uh
a polling historical polling trend line
on that race and it is true that
eventually DeSantis surged as the
election got close but it wasn't over
the summer when Trump claims that his
endorsement in 48 hours turned the race
around it was months later now you you
can debate whether it was thanks to
Trump's endorsement months earlier I'm
not even trying to have that debate with
you the story that's being told DeSantis
was dead
and then I endorsed them and 48 hours
later he was absolutely crushing in the
polls it's just not what the polling
data shows when you look at it
retrospectively so I do think that you
know Trump's in a position where there's
the real reason he's angry with DeSantis
and then there's what stuff can he use
to criticize the santis there's a little
bit of a dissonance between the two the
real reason Trump's furious at DeSantis
is that DeSantis not ruling out running
is seen by Trump as totally disloyal the
problem is Trump's going after DeSantis
for like for example saying Trump's uh
sorry this Trump says desantis's covet
numbers are terrible they're mediocre
they're not terrible they're not good
Florida is very mediocre in most metrics
so when Trump used to praise DeSantis on
kovid now he attacks him on covid the
truth is it was was both sort of like
it's not great in Florida but they
benefit from the warm weather and people
being outdoors and so like the numbers
aren't as bad as they could be he wants
to cut and gut Social Security
and he voted for a study group proposal
that was non-binding which would have
raised the retirement age is that a sort
of cut yes did he really vote for the
cut well everybody knew it wasn't going
anywhere it was just a study group
proposal is that a really strong
critique particularly when Trump has
also said I would look at entitlements
not really and so Trump if this really
gets going is going to have to find
something a little more solid I guess I
would say with which he can go after Ron
DeSantis we have a voicemail number that
number is 219 to David P we've been
playing a lot of nice positive
voicemails lately here's just an
old-fashioned person who doesn't like
the show
guys show is disgusting and I see how I
see why David Pac-Man has a such a big
mouth that's how he got his last name
Pac-Man right have a good day
is that a a Pac-Man video game joke or
something like that
uh uh I don't know not exactly
electrifying Us in terms of the delivery
but
all right I guess uh
I appreciate the voicemail and uh okay
bonus show today it's going to be
fantastic producer Pat will join me
Don Lemon
says he was fired by CNN
Don Lemon says CNN didn't even try to
communicate with him directly they told
him through his agent CNN says we
actually did try to meet with them
uh what's going on and how does this
relate to the Tucker Carlson firing and
what else is going to happen secondly
the Vegas to California bullet train
which we've talked about before very
strongly now has bipartisan support will
it happen
will people say it's a waste of money
well of course they will and lastly the
Supreme Court is going to decide
can public officials block people who
criticize them on social media or is it
in some sense a violation of the First
Amendment it's an interesting case with
far-reaching implications all of those
stories and more will be on today's
bonus show David Pacman does not have a
soul he doesn't have a soul okay but it
will be on the bonus show that I can
tell you you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code indicted for a discount and you can
use the coupon code indicated for an
even larger discount we have a fantastic
week of shows for you today remember
subscribe free
at youtube.com slash the David Pacman
show I will see you on the bonus show
for tomorrow